the jurogan experience chromebooks are
actually pretty logical because most
mostly what people do is scroll yeah you
just go online and scroll well i don't
leave the house so what do i need a
laptop for
are you like uh completely locked down
oh i just met because i'm i don't like i
love my house
it wasn't because of corona this has
been the case for many years
so you haven't altered your behavior
much at all because of corona because
it's what you've always done
well i've altered it in that like i want
to travel more but everywhere
everyone's closed there's nowhere to go
are you worried about the virus at all
no i'm worried about the response to the
virus and
and this has given some very very bad
people
some very useful information about how
much crap people put up with
yes and and that we're at a point where
it's just like
oh yeah we're you know we're just gonna
open up even though the metrics are
worse than when we're closed
but now uh double masks why not and
there was an onion article from 99 that
said
drinking dog pee lessens risks of cancer
snickering researchers say
and i'm telling you if they told people
to start drinking dog p people be on
twitter wondering what the best breed if
fauci said it
he they would do it yeah there would be
a large percentage of the population
that would be sucking some
and would be yelling at you that you're
not doing it
yes because how dare you not drink the
golden retriever p
yeah which is the golden standard of pee
to keep grandma from dying
well i think that's one of the things
that's really fascinating about this
pandemic is that it's happening during
the time
of social media where we've never had
anything like this before
where group think is encouraged and
enforced
and people there also because of the
pandemics so many people are just
online all day sure because they're
unemployed or they're just
they're at work from home and they're
not really working they're just on
twitter all day
and you're seeing this like these really
crazy behavior patterns it's
like people ganging up on people i don't
think they're crazy at all
i think you know i had this tweet was a
huge backlash and i said if you
replace the term coronavirus or jews all
of a sudden the behavior of 1930s
germany makes a lot more sense
because one of the big questions back in
the day is how did hitler pull this off
how do you convince a population of
educated
people to behave in just the most in
human ways
and what we're seeing is when low status
people are given an excuse to assert
dominance over other people for whatever
reason
illegitimate in that case somewhat
legitimate in this case they will champ
at the bit
to tell you to sit down and shut up and
obey it decentralizes the enforcement
mechanism
i was on the subway in new york i've
been new york all my life i've never
seen anything like this
where an older man in his 50s was
yelling at an asian dude
who wasn't like it's a rickshaw he was
just like a regular asian dude
standing over him screaming where's your
mask go back where you came from
and it's like if you're this concerned
about the virus why are you coming close
to him
you don't care about the virus this is
your excuse to be dominant and
aggressive or someone
in the most despicable way possible
that's a lot of what you see
in in social media right a lot of the
really shitty behavior
is an excuse to be shitty you know like
they found and
in right their shitty behavior being
violently anti-racist is the only way
lowest status whites have an excuse to
be dominant and better than somebody
else yeah this is the one leg up they
have
so this becomes their identity you don't
see it that much from people who are
minorities
or people who are immigrants certainly
people who are gay unless they went to
college
but you see it all the time with these
lowest status whites especially white
women
they can't they're tripping over
themselves now they have a chance to
yell at someone
and feel empowered it's really
reprehensible behavior and if you want
to stop this behavior that's not the way
to do it
if you want to stop ignorant behavior
educate people
be friendly with them say hey you know
what i come from this background
you probably don't realize what you're
saying but when you're saying this this
you're talking about my grandma and when
someone comes at you like that you're
like oh crap i'm sorry
you know i didn't anything invite and
you've educated that person very quickly
i don't care about that
it's all about dominance always and what
do i need to say to get you to do what i
want
yeah and because of social media they
have this weird
little outlet now where a person isn't
just talking to someone on a subway
now they're talking to everyone that's
on that feed they're talking to
and a lot of people chime in that also
want to reinforce this kind of shitty
behavior
a lot of other low status people that
are finally getting
their voice heard on something and it's
all it's like it's irrefutable like wear
a [ __ ] mask
like that's one of those irrefutable
things no one's going to argue with you
it's like if you're wearing a mask why
don't you need a wear mask it's like you
don't need a condom and a diaphragm
right
um when we were kids it would have been
unimaginable
for someone to say i yelled at my
grandparents at thanksgiving dinner for
x y and z reason
everyone would be like jock nerd
whatever like what dude what is wrong
with you
and now they get applause now they'll go
on facebook i told off my grandma
i told off my so-called racist dad
homophobic mom
and everyone said good for you for
standing up for yourself no you're an
ass
yeah did you see that tick tock of the
white kid
talking about how all white people are
racist oh yeah
it's amazing because it's a perfect
example that it's illogical what he's
saying like that he's saying that he's
racist
right just by virtue of being white and
it's it's so
bizarre to watch because he's a
caricature he literally
is like a parody he's he's he's like one
of those youtube comedian parodies
of these social justice warriors it it
harkens i i made the point that uh
corporate america has done a much better
job of importing maoist communism than
the chinese party ever did
but this was what mao invented north
korea still has it these struggle
sessions
where you get up with other colleagues
and you have to denounce yourself
and say what you did that was horrible
and they all berate you
and then you point out oh i saw joe
doing this joe i saw mike doing this
and this was their kind of community
because it keeps everyone
watching each other all the time yeah
and it keeps everyone so-called honest
and by honest they mean subservient to
the regime
and there was a phone call conference
call from northwestern university i
believe
when all the law students had to get in
the call and say i'm white and i'm
racist
yes this happens increasingly where you
are
ordered to say you're at the very least
racially insensitive and it's like let
me tell you something as an immigrant
like this crap does not uh sit well with
me it's just
totally foreign to my thinking yeah and
it's such this as
this um relic of american puritanism you
know this kind of like we're all such
sinners and we have to denounce
ourselves it's this weird mix of woodrow
wilson and chairman mao
wow that's an interesting way of putting
it but i think you're onto something
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost all
for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience